oh you can't
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
what's up everybody dopaziola here hope
you're having a dope as day
guys this is the dope as usual podcast
we are here to talk about problems
life accomplishments drugs and
everything in between
this is episode i believe 15. episode 15
guys all right
today marks the third month anniversary
we started on february 8th it is now may
8th
so three months old today [ __ ] yeah
shout out to everyone on patreon
um everyone on our twitter our instagram
our youtube we just hit
77 000 subscribers which is [ __ ]
awesome so thank you guys so much
uh for supporting everything's looking
great so thank you guys so much so
new episode solo podcast we're coming
hot off [ __ ] three
uh we're coming off a three guest
podcast in a row
if you guys didn't see it my mom a lot
of people like you're just mean to your
mom like hey man
she was a lot meaner to me and it was
fun and so i enjoyed it
she had fun she wasn't pissed so that
was good we had eric kahn come on
you guys loved it biggest episode yet so
shout out to you guys for watching
which is very [ __ ] cool and fabian
alamar uh dropped last week
funny [ __ ] man so we've had
three really good guests in a row
what's up now it's just our turn to hang
out this is another solo episode
marty and i just talking [ __ ]
so since i haven't talked to you guys in
a while so let's catch up what's been
going on in our lives
everything everything's fast as [ __ ]
everything's moving quick
that's it that's really what's going on
every day i wake up going [ __ ] all right
let's knock these things out it's it's
good
it's the best time of my life it's
everything's circulating well
everything's working out push trees the
clothing companies doing [ __ ]
awesome our taxes are done we're no
longer [ __ ] delinquents
we did all our taxes for all the years
we [ __ ] up
everything's looking good i'm an adult
kinda now now that i did my taxes which
is
pretty [ __ ] cool um i went to bed
early
once since i've seen you guys last
things are turning up all right things
are going
i'm not watching youtube never mind
i went to bed at seven o'clock this
morning i was watching sport
youtube compilation so i'll take that
back anyway guys i'm trying to grow up
so
i'm gonna hop right into this real quick
i need to talk about some [ __ ] because
it's been ruining my [ __ ] life for
months and i
know some of you guys noticed so here we
go let's talk about it
health let's uh talk about health right
so i am prone for some reason to getting
sinus infections since i was about 18.
when i was at my grandma's on sixth
street than when we brought up on the
podcast many times
1142 west 6th street boy merced that's
my grandma and grandpa's house
there's black mold in there my whole
life so i didn't know black mold
super deadly to people it can cause
really bad infections in your body
i didn't know when we moved i always had
sinus infections but i didn't really
have allergies i know it's a weird story
but i need to tell you guys the back
story first right
um then i got a sinus infection really
really bad where i couldn't stand up and
then when i stood up i'd get sick start
spinning and start throwing up it was
very weird it was the month me and rosie
started dating and that's why i knew
rosie was down as [ __ ] because she took
care of me for like two weeks
i was throwing up it was it was horrible
dude but i haven't been sick i haven't
had science infection like that
since january i mean until january
so we started this podcast february 8th
right
josh wolf episode everything was fine
next full solo episode
okay i feel good the day ryan sickler
was here guys if you guys have been
watching since the start i mean since
the start it's been three [ __ ] months
if you guys been watching for a couple
months do you remember the ryan stickler
episode where i kept like
you could see a couple parts where i'm
rubbing my eye i'm rubbing my head
like i'm just touching my face and you
guys have seen it on instagram
because people ask why are you [ __ ]
rubbing your head guys i have had
a stinging ass headache since february
9th no no it's like february 15th
it's [ __ ] may i've had a [ __ ]
sinus infection for almost three months
solid straight and i've had glass
i wear glasses now when i edit because i
thought i was going blind
i think it's a science infection just
[ __ ] up my eyes so guys i
have something they think it's they
think it's called chronic
centitus chronic centitus or something
it's whack dude i've had a
inflamed head i basically haven't been
able to think so i haven't been editing
a lot i haven't been on the computer
that's why i haven't been doing live
streams
because looking at my phone trying to
read the comments i start feeling sick
i start feeling my throw up and then i
get like a bad moon why the [ __ ] would i
want to be in a bad mood talking to my
fans and [ __ ]
so that's why i haven't been doing a lot
of videos the podcast is the only thing
i can do i'm just sitting here
i'm talking i don't have to like
actively make a video i just i just been
feeling sick guys
like all right so basically at the end
of february i got around to antibiotics
it didn't do [ __ ] a week or two later 10
days later i went and got a steroid i
had to get a steroid
didn't do [ __ ] i waited another month
because i thought it was gonna go away
no guys so it still didn't go away i'm
on my day four
of my really really really strong
antibiotics now my head's feeling a lot
better
as you can tell i feel like i i feel
like i look
different i'm looking at these videos
and i can see like how much
my [ __ ] head hurts every podcast
we've done
i'm gonna be honest during the ryan
stickler when i almost passed out
there was a time i almost [ __ ]
fainted i thought i was gonna fake my
head was hurting so bad it just
i dealt with it so i've been dealing
with it for months so marty's been
asking how's your head feel like
it's been sad to [ __ ] watch like [ __ ]
every time we facetime you're just like
every time i'm holding my [ __ ] head
it's just it's throbbing
out my eye and my eyebrow like right now
it hurts it hurts right now but it
didn't hurt all day today so
that's what i've been dealing with i
know it sounds all sad and [ __ ] at least
you've got the [ __ ] taken care of it's
actually a good
thing that you're saying because yeah
that's true did what you needed to do
got it handled and it's feeling better
right
it's feeling a lot better i got a
voluntary shot and i hate needles
we haven't talked about that too my mom
brought it up on the podcast
where i've escaped many doctor's office
rooms just screaming running
but yeah i got a shot i'm feeling a
little bit better
things are working out all right so i
just wanted to talk about that because
it's
really been it's been weighing on me
that every day
every time we're here after we're done
like yo my head is [ __ ] throbbing
it's just
it's not fun so i'm happy as hell to be
okay
i'm feeling a lot better so guys let's
get into this podcast i know everyone on
the [ __ ] roads like what the [ __ ] is
this guy talking about
talking about my health all right i'm
talking about how [ __ ] it up it is and
how i don't take care of it
so sinus infection as i light a joint
sinus infection all right
please be careful all right i don't even
know how i got this [ __ ]
i i have no idea but we're okay now
didn't you say you had raging sinus
infections as a kid or some [ __ ]
uh when i was like 18 19 yeah really
really bad ones but
dude this one's been long it's been four
three months that's
that's three months every day headache
all day yo i've been feeling like i want
to die
it sucks you know yeah i talk to you
every [ __ ] day
that's how the standard cold usually
goes for me i'm good for one a year i go
down for a [ __ ] month
bro it's bad it's bad i went to the
doctor this last time i even say it
i went to the doctor you put the steps
or the the not the stethoscope whatever
the [ __ ] it's called i'm not a doctor
puts it in my ear for 0.5 seconds he
puts it in my ear and goes whoa
backs up he looks at me goes does your
ear hurt oh no
because your ear is infected that's why
you said it
is infected he said it like you're
dying are you okay i looked at him like
i'm okay it's so red and infected
i'm gonna put you on this this this and
i i said is that where my head hurts
because
probably yeah and that's what i thought
you're a doctor
why don't you tell me why my head hurts
what am i guessing
and we're both probably that's what the
doctor do that he's like you know your
nose is [ __ ] you got the deviated
septum going right that's why you got
the nose whistle
nah [ __ ] i'm coming to you about the
nose whistle why do i [ __ ] i got the
nose whistle yeah yeah dude uh
i bet you never went deaf over having
your ear get clogged with earwax though
you did yeah right when i moved here it
was [ __ ] horrible i almost went
insane
why why why'd you just make it just
slowly i don't know i [ __ ]
because i used up q-tips i guess that's
what they said oh and you're on the east
coast your whole life you've never done
an ear candle
well i did when i started [ __ ] going
deaf yeah disgusting it's disgusting but
was worse
what was more disgusting was going to
the er and having them
plunge water out of my like into my ear
and it like shot out this giant rock of
wax
no and my hearing came back into focus
it was the most amazing feeling
i've ever felt marty ow
it was amazing but like having that go
on makes you want to rip your ear off
and i let it let [ __ ] linger for months
i never even talked about this i
couldn't hear as a kid i ever tell you
that
i have immaculate hearing now it's weird
rosie but you hear i'm like i
[ __ ] hear it from a mile away i have
crazy good hearing but
i couldn't hear as a kid i had tubes in
my ears you know that it is
yeah cam had that oh yeah oh [ __ ] oh
yeah
i had tubes in my ears that's why i can
do this for everybody at home you can't
see it
but that's why i can do this everybody
watching on the podcast can see watch
oh god watch i can pop my here guys
that's my ear not my tongue watch
oh so my party trick started in
fourth grade fifth grade you guys ready
for this for everyone at home
driving that didn't see that for
everyone driving that didn't see that
um i popped my ear
i found out how to do that because i got
tubes in my ears because i couldn't hear
[ __ ]
i got tubes in my ears and they itch
because i had open cuts you know surgery
so i'm sitting there scratching my ear
in class like oh my god it hurts
and i did my pinky and i like you know
what i mean i just try to alleviate some
of the pressure
and it went i looked around like what
the [ __ ] was that
it scared the [ __ ] the [ __ ] come on
imagine that happened to me the first
time that's crazy look i remember my dad
taught me to do that
with your cheek yeah no i didn't do my
ear
i used to do it i realized that was a
freak same way with the double jointed
thumbs
yeah that's pretty cool people started
[ __ ] freaking out like i was like a
quasimodo when i started to realize
everything you're like
a little kid down there like wow yeah
even now though that freaks people out
yeah i could do this thing with smoke
have i showed you the smoke thing
i'm sure no i haven't listen
the small i don't know where you're all
right you guys you guys for everyone
what are we getting into what does
podcast turn into real quick
this is for youtube entertainment
because everyone on the radio
you can't see this but i'm about to
produce smoke out of my body
without smoking are you ready marty i
know you're going to trip i don't know
where that's about
you're going to trip balls everybody on
youtube
get [ __ ] ready for this all right
i've been doing this in sixth grade my
cousin adrian showed me how to do it
because his cut his brother billy showed
him i asked my science teacher miss
bentley what it means and she looked at
me
and just went i don't know what that is
it's ready
before i ever smoked ever i can do this
so it's not like i'm burping smoke up
watch
did you see it marty yes did you see it
yeah
how would you have started to do that
first because my cousin adrian did it
and i go what did you just do how did
you just make smoke come out of your
mouth because at the
time uh cigarette bubble gum cigarettes
were the coolest thing in the world
because you could pretend you're smoking
everyone i knew smoked salt parents so
it's like
that's cool how do you do it oh some
david blaine had to give him two dollars
for him to show me how to do it
two dollars in the sixth grade or
seventh grade that was detrimental it's
a good investment though look at us
oh yeah so if you out there i know a lot
of you in the comments gonna go i can do
that
bro aren't you aren't you like a god as
a kid
oh you can make smoke we used to do it
in class we used to do it in class dude
just to [ __ ] with people they go what
the [ __ ] and you can't say anything
while you're in class and teachers go
what the [ __ ] you doing
thomas is smoking talking about yo it's
it's i used to get get it to where it
would like ghost
cloud it's i somebody figured out leave
it in the comments how the [ __ ] did i do
that is it steam
pressure from are you asking me or are
you [ __ ] with me i'm asking you what
is it
i don't know what the [ __ ] i just
watched i assumed it was weed smoke but
you're saying
no no i did this before i ever smoked i
could show you i could show you
i wouldn't believe that you just have
like thousands
no big shocker there but but dude
preposterous how the [ __ ] did we get
onto this oh my ear thing
listen we're gonna put the answer out on
patreon
i i don't know how it works i don't know
how it works but
how the [ __ ] do we get onto this topic i
don't know but here we go
health that's how it was i got tubes in
my ears and i started it scratching them
that's how i got onto it so guys i've
been doing this as a child
it i don't know what the [ __ ] it is but
it's pretty damn cool
and uh the ear thing is awesome too but
maybe that's why i get sinus infections
i know you're putting popping air into
my
ear canal and [ __ ] well you're allergic
to weeds so you
probably have i'm not allergic to if you
guys didn't notice during the aircon
episode did you notice it
right here no i don't know during the
ericon episode about an hour in
right here if you look i get a huge welt
on my eye because i touched weed and i
touched my face i'm allergic to wheat
for someone that just smokes weed all
day
when i touch weed and the and it gets in
my pores like if it gets in my pores not
just my hands if it gets in my pores
i get a little hive like i got stung by
a bee
it goes away after about 20 minutes but
you're gonna be able to see on the eric
con episode it starts to
form it's in the thumbnail marty
the thumbnail that we made i have a
[ __ ] thing growing on my head
and then it goes away by the end of the
podcast so yeah guys uh i saw i'm i'm
shocked nobody else saw it honestly now
everybody's gonna go back
i see i can't not see it i already know
you almost had a goddamn asthma attack
before the million subscriber video
oh that was bad that was bad
i didn't know i thought you were joking
like you're allergic to weed
i [ __ ] rolled for everyone just know
on my main channel dopaziola
i do a lot of weed content and uh i
rolled a quarter pound joint so i got
a quarter pound worth of weed from the
club put it all on the table grind it
all up rolled a [ __ ] joint as big as
your arm
so i broke out in hives
because i was touching all the wee
different poor different trichomes
touching my face broke out
i was all red and blotchy it's just what
happens to me man
just the past like four years and it's
not like you're under a bunch of lights
on 4k cameras either while this is going
on
there you go that's probably not helping
it's probably not healthy
um this weed is delicious this gmo i'm
not smoking og
so gmo is fire so here we go
are you still a man without weed are you
still scavenging and getting what you
can or are you back to
are you still a man without weed you
guys i know marty said that you're like
marty what are you you don't know what
you're talking about
marty's right i have been weedless for
about two and a half three months
and i don't mean weedless like i'm not
smoking weed i haven't had more than a
quarter pound to a pound in over three
months i've been buying weed from the
damn
shop i've been buying away from the shop
guys
because i've been finding this one
strain and this one
uh company that sells it and it's
[ __ ] fire as
clean oh gee i have been a regular kid
i haven't bought weed like that you're
not a regular kid when you go into the
dispensary and you're [ __ ] podcasting
your videos are playing on the walls and
[ __ ] that was actually pretty cool
that was pretty [ __ ] cool i walked in
it was already on them
um but i'm saying like i'm i usually buy
a pound of wheat that's what i do i buy
a pound of wheat and i [ __ ]
smoke it until it's gone i buy half
pound it depends
i haven't found any weed worth worth
buying so i've been buying
eight jars but like a lot at a time but
still
i've been spending so much money dude
and i've been using at a legal shop
so it's all on my bank account statement
so i don't even want to look at how much
[ __ ] money i have spent on weed in
three months everybody buying weed shops
you're brave
you're bri i was smoking eighth up on
the way home though so it's
it's more like
is it worth it but i need weed and this
weed is delicious i should have bought
all of it from him
i like that you're relating to us
regular [ __ ] with this [ __ ] now you
gotta feel it's weird to me dude i
remember the last time i bought a sack
and lost out on money every time i smoke
weed
i gain money back because i'm selling
weed
so no matter what you know what i mean
until when i lose i win
yeah until and i watched rainy day last
night exactly i watched training day at
1 30 in the morning last night and then
i watched total recall
oh honestly you [ __ ] um
i i uh ran out of weed if you guys are
if you guys follow my story times
closely when john disappeared i ran out
of weed you guys know that and then i
met stinky ass dan
i went to a house party and i had to buy
an aetherweed
and i remember buying the eighth of
wheat for 50 and going
i could have made 300 right now and
smoked this ate for free
and i was i remember how [ __ ]
infuriated i was
so mad and that's the last time i ever
let myself do that
until i stopped selling weed again in
like 2000
what 14 13 i stopped selling wheat
and i just buying pounds so when i buy
pounds i just
it just works out for me i get a way
[ __ ] better deal and that's how i
smoke
uh so freely that's why i smoke so much
because it's mad cheap to me
so um marty how the [ __ ] do you got this
topic sorry guys for everyone out there
i feel like i'm all dead and [ __ ] it's
what time is it it's it's 10 30 at night
i mean
yeah you probably should say that you're
doing a goddamn movie marathon last
night and got like three hours of sleep
oh yeah i went to bed at seven in the
morning i could not sleep last night
what time do you usually go to sleep bro
there's never been a time
there's never been a schedule my whole
life um
i don't know i just stayed up as [ __ ]
though
i don't do that [ __ ] on purpose it sucks
dude i'll be laying in bed it was 7 in
the morning i went to lay down it took
me 40 minutes to lay down to sleep still
i was just sitting there just you guys
uh you guys know those movies when uh
like dudes lose their memory and then
they're getting it back and everything's
coming back you know what i mean like to
get flashes near that
that's my brain when i try to sleep i
see pictures
of things that i've done or seen or
movies and i'll play
i can play full movies in my head and
it's the most annoying [ __ ] in the world
i hate it but it's so fun sometimes when
i was a kid
it was definitely fun reciting the whole
movie and watching it in your head
because you wanted to see i wanted to
see if i could do it that's why i was
insomniac i'd just be up all night
but yeah there's no set schedule marty
i'm not like you i wish i was i
i wasn't always like that i had to force
myself i wish i was dude
i can't do it i can't do it i don't know
i wish i could it's the best getting
into a routine with it is the best thing
i've ever done
i need to do it dude because i don't
even notice sleep
i don't know what day it is it's the
same every day i just know i'm being
i because i used to like always be tired
on some level and it used to make me a
dick
but now my body's just on normal i wake
up and i'm just awake
really yeah i'm i'm
there's a reason i think i fall asleep
or i get really tired when i drive
and i get really tired i fall asleep
when i get haircuts because i can't
touch my phone i can't answer emails i
can't do business and i can't talk
i can't do anything so i'm driving like
that
middle of the day middle of [ __ ] day
i have a homie named one
he has 10 kids right they're all
homeschooled they all play an instrument
they all do sports and
they are homeschooled by his wife bless
her soul he's the man right
he falls asleep everywhere
you know why marty you want to hear me
my friend won i'm going to tell you with
his
schedule you ready he stays up for 48
hours and then sleeps for about three
hours four hours
stays at 48 hours sleeps for about three
or four hours okay
that's his life and he micro doses every
morning mushrooms and acid
that's goals every morning whether or
not he was awake before the night
or not so no matter what when morning
comes he's re-upping on his [ __ ] because
he's like
very into that stuff but he's microphone
so he's not getting [ __ ] up but
he's every time rosie can vouch every
time he comes to my house in la and he's
get and i know he sits on the couch he's
asleep no matter what there's 30 people
in the house the second he's on the
couch done
because he's so [ __ ] busy he's so he
works
through the night through the night dude
through the night that's the best part
because like yours there is no laying
there and hoping you fall asleep
as soon as you lay down you're asleep
and then like now
then after you do it a while then you
start waking up like a few minutes
before the alarm
yeah thing is with me is i always have
something to do there's so much to do
it was uh it was the biggest thing in my
life was to take control of that
and because my clients ran my life for
so long
that i had to like all right
i don't work all-nighters anymore
it was a huge statement and i i mean i
do when i have to
but it's not on the regular anymore yeah
yeah i i totally understand what you're
saying
but sometimes that's the way the [ __ ]
it's the way it is dude i [ __ ] have
to
they don't have to it's just no one else
can do it for me that's why
um yo i feel like we're
over here on heroin i feel like this is
a heroin podcast and everyone's just
talking real
slow and we're just kind of chilling no
what the [ __ ] let's wait
wake up all right here we go let's go
wake up no more sleeping this you're
slamming heroin on the mom episode
i was i was i was uh my mom doesn't know
what kind of person i am i told her that
i feel like you don't know who i
am i i don't i don't think she does
because it's like mom
if you don't see that and go yo what's
wrong with you what's wrong with you
then you don't have a sense of humor
because if i saw somebody do that go
what the [ __ ] just mid-sentence while
she's talking
yo i don't ever told you this all right
i'm gonna tell everybody right now
i do this thing all right i do this
thing i'm not i'm actually
[ __ ] you i'm mad proud of it it's
[ __ ] funny so
i've done it to a lot of my friends
i've almost made a few homies puke over
it
sometimes when people talk too [ __ ]
much and they're talking about nothing
and it's repetitive and redundant and i
don't want to hear it anymore
it's hard for me to go yo can we stop
talking about this i feel rude
even though they're rude for talking
about nothing
and making me stay there that's rude you
know what i'm saying like
so this is a thing i do there's a thing
i do
how do you get someone to stop talking
about something
change the subject and you not be the
dick about it they're just like what the
[ __ ]
and they forget about it how do you do
it that was my thing marty how am i
going to do it
because up man what would you say right
now ear beating is offensive
it's a [ __ ] offensive bro sometimes
when you're talking about [ __ ]
nothing i'm
i'm like first of all i hate small talk
on all levels beyond small talk there's
getting into ear beating territory where
now it's offensive
yes so what would you do right now if i
was if i was doing that to you and you
didn't want me to be mad at you by you
going thomas can you shut the [ __ ] up
you know can we change the subject if
you didn't want me to get offended
you needed it to stop immediately and
change the subject without you saying
word how do you do it everybody at home
participate
i pull out my my air pokey and starfire
exactly you do something that makes him
go
what the [ __ ] so you guys want to know
my thing start poking your eyeball or
something
no are you ready marty i do this to a
lot of my friends
when they keep talking about nothing or
i just do it just to
do it just because they know like hey i
wasn't even talking that much why are
you doing that [ __ ] to me it's just a
thing i do
so i'll stare at somebody's eyes are you
ready party
i've never done it to you because you
don't do this to me your mom was telling
a real story all right my mom was
telling a real story here we go
this is what i do to people i'll stare
at him and just do this
and spit in my hand oh god one
disgusting oh
no i fake echo
like fake rub it on their face or my
own face but to certain friends
i'll just do it for real and i do it
because i do this
i spit my hand i stare at their face and
they go what the [ __ ] and i go
yo you gotta shut the [ __ ] up and then
what are you doing why'd you spit just
tell me to shut up like nah nah
that's funnier to me and like yo you're
disgusting
i know but now look we're on a different
subject
[Laughter]
the little dude in my head is [ __ ]
dying right now yeah
the thing in me is like yeah that was
hilarious
because it's funny i did it to charlie
charlie the guy that helps me film dope
zelda videos
i did it to him while he was talking
while we were filming and i have it on
tape where i went
and he just stops ah you could hear him
what the [ __ ]
he loved his i'm gonna start doing that
to people i go right
sometimes people need to shut the [ __ ]
up and if they don't think it's funny
they think you're weird and they're not
going to keep talking to you that's a
win
thanks thanks [ __ ] off
yes i love it dude but i can only do it
to like
people i know i don't want to do it to a
stranger that's mean
yeah that's mean i wouldn't do it to a
stranger but sometimes
one time all right there's gonna get a
lot of fans thinking was it me
it wasn't you one time there was one guy
at an event
that talked to me for so long marty
while i was running my business
which is cool like i've had people talk
to me for a long time it's great
but he started getting redundant and
repetitive and this [ __ ] talked
to me i looked at my phone it was
almost 30 minutes almost 30 minutes
and i'm standing there like oh really
trying not to get mad
and for some reason in my head i went
knock this [ __ ] out
why did my brain do that and so he would
stop talking
yeah that's logical that's it whatever
you went or you could just be like yo
i'm busy yo if i killed this
[ __ ] i was thinking like
you are wasting my time so hard you're
now rude you see
all these people waiting to try to talk
to me there was a line of people like
you can get a picture like
yeah once like once i felt weird i felt
rude like yo can we stop your
conversation right now
because you know i'll be taking this
common decency yeah that's what it was
time and the people behind you
i i'm like dude i'll talk to you i'll
keep talking to you but i
you're now talking to the cashier while
there's a line behind you
that's exactly what you're doing like
you're rude you're [ __ ] rude
but the guy did it to me once and i
remember i told rosie like i almost
punched him i felt so like
played that i wanted to punch him what a
logical thought a half hour is a long
time for a [ __ ] ear beating
and i'm running the booth yeah that
means rosie's taking all the orders by
herself crazy
if i'm talking i was pissed um how the
[ __ ] do we get oh there's a get ready
for these comedy shows because
that's fun no that's different i'm not
sitting there selling shirts
having to pack bowls for people you can
arrange pictures so people can take
pictures
and i'm filming marty just film myself
remember that so remember doing
all of these things and going [ __ ] okay
the 20s are in this side of my pocket
the tens are in the side of my pocket
okay
all right cool cool then i got to go do
my rounds and take pictures and do my
[ __ ] and you know
record so me and rosie would switch off
at the events for about 45 minutes and
i'd come back
because i can't leave her there though
this wasn't this didn't happen to be the
same event where you're falling all over
the [ __ ] bags and
fell on top of the woman right now i
don't think we talked about on this
podcast man
i did something once i got
too [ __ ] up i got too [ __ ] up once
i'm not going to talk about it
we'll talk about another solo podcast
it's too long i can't even get into it
if you want to do it it's called edibles
gone wrong
and it's on dopaziola channel on youtube
go watch it
i ruined the woman's life you told me
the story organically and i'm like is
this a story
that's right and i went i haven't done a
story time on this have i
so ridiculous remember we were talking
about i brought the story up to you and
go i should do a story time on that
there's a lot of those that start
talking and go
i haven't told this story i don't think
dude a lot of things have happened to me
and people go
how are so many things happen to you i
think you're lying
it's just the way you tell the story man
yo i [ __ ] fell
and ate [ __ ] today and scraped my knee
yo so this is what happened this morning
i woke up and i was real [ __ ] tired
right i had this [ __ ] song stuck in
my head i'm trying to get you to where i
was
and i was [ __ ] walking by this dude
and he stuck like [ __ ] you know what
piss
but like in a bar like you have to
describe it
like that scene in reservoir dogs nah
man you go in what kind of soap was it
was that powdery [ __ ] in high school
was that liquid stuff you know what i
mean when he's trying to tell tim roth
how to
tell the story to gangsters like you
just got to tell the story man
what were you doing while it happened
can i get you inside my head while i
while you listen to me and if you can
then i win
and i'm happy with that i just want
people to feel like they're there
that's why people like music that's why
people like comedy that's why mac dre is
one of my favorite rappers
everything is descriptive and i can see
everything he's saying
it's i [ __ ] love him yeah if you can
paint a picture with your words
people with your words i heard somebody
say like people are it's in our
like biology to like storytelling that's
one of the oldest things people do
it's the oldest thing of all time i
think it says water fight
fight water [ __ ] cat taxes
tax and taxes in some way shape or form
okay
people been getting taxed since the dawn
of dude [ __ ] you know what's crazy guys
i was thinking
you know gangs tax people and [ __ ] or
certain neighborhoods and i thought
the government taxes me 53
that's like a god that's like me buying
a pound i sell it and go yo yo yo
you know the apartment complex guy like
yeah he needs half the money
[ __ ] you all right well you're gonna go
to jail
[ __ ] that's what the government did and
went
what you do about it huh
that's what they did have a good day man
50 52
you're good but at least when things go
wrong like a pandemic they have
well not even that you gotta remember
i'm driving on a road who paid for it
we gotta if not i'm driving on dirt
roads so that's why i'm like
taxes cool i'll pay them another thing
is i'm happy to pay my taxes now because
that means i'm doing legal things and
i'm not gonna go to jail
and i'm not gonna look over my [ __ ]
shoulder i love it it's the best thing
ever my bank account is
clean i had a 800 this week on my credit
score
i was [ __ ] tripping out 804 don't be
saying 800 804 i saw it
with 804. it'll take you a week to ruin
that [ __ ] in 15 years to build it back
up that's a true statement
just like a kid that [ __ ] is evil yeah
dude um so back onto this i
i don't know what the [ __ ] we're talking
about and i
i don't know what it is but i feel like
i need to
[Music]
make these people that are driving right
now wake the [ __ ] up so wake the [ __ ] up
all right
here we go i know i've been talking kind
of slow and [ __ ] that's because i'm on
three hours of sleep and it's 11 o'clock
at night
and i'm tired but i'm [ __ ] here and
i'm awake i'm smoking this gmo it's
delicious here we go let's start talking
podcast boom one of my other notes that
i'm pretending not to look at
podcast one of my other two bullet
points
i know i didn't even do that many bullet
points yo wasn't there
we did a bullet point for a guest one
time and it said drugs
talk about them oh it was for a solo
podcast i'm writing it like i'm talking
to myself that's why
it was like wrap it up the ending
closed part come on full that's from uh
wrap it up beat wrap it up b that's from
uh chappelle show uh
when they put the box down wrap
it up that's why half the things i say i
think are just from
references men like a lot of things that
i say are just references
when you tell me about okay dave
chappelle's got a podcast
the midnight miracle i [ __ ] tyler
quality yeah yo all three of these full
mo stuff dave chappelle to look polly
you know yassin babe is my stuff yeah
yeah yeah i see him right there
no i'm just trying to read that are you
[ __ ] serious that's crazy the one
thing i really loved about the chapelle
show is he brought out artists quality
and all that he brought him out at the
end remember
kanye came out what was it
my hood my heart my that's the song
right the [ __ ] kanye one i think it
was with most death
that's on the [ __ ] college dropout
album right that's the first album one
of the first albums i ever had burned
it's where i almost died in tahoe
i'll listen to kanye west and jadakiss
and eight ball
i respect man jdk is one of my favorite
all-time rappers i respect you said that
yeah dude my friend anthony avila he
burned him for me
he burned cd uh three cds for me and
then we drove to
to tahoe and my grandpa tom almost oh
doiled
everybody we were in a van and almost
went off a cliff
i just showed my kids that scene from
tommy boy
here comes the meat wagon wait what if
not from time away from black sheep yeah
from black sheep okay
i'm like tommy boy i'm searching all of
it in my head like nah
that ain't in it black sheep's great
hello washington is something i scream a
lot when i jump in the pools
i just [ __ ] love it all time ready
wake the [ __ ] up the best fall scene of
any movie of all time is black sheep
chris farley falls down that damn hill
and i need to know
did he do that himself no are you sure
because it [ __ ] looked like it
it straight up looked like chris farley
hang on
smoke branch there's nobody home i think
[ __ ] goes again
yo he i see where the bat came into the
cabin and he's like it's awesome i was
born
it's in my head yo david spade man
i love his ass so hold on they made
tommy boy and they were just like this
is so amazing we got to run this back
and
run it again it was the it was the
kevin hart and [ __ ] rock thing going
this is golden more like black except
these ones are like
you know comedy classics i haven't seen
all the rock in kevin hart movies
but the rock's the man come on how are
you gonna not [ __ ] with the rock
he's just he's like the barack obama of
actors
he's just got a genuine like you don't
know
you hate him nope nobody hates him
everybody loves him
there we go that's pretty much what he's
doing and uh
you know kevin hart he's just funny
i always think of kevin hart from
[ __ ] uh 40 year old virgin i'm gonna
come back in here
cop yo mommy's hella little
yo that scene is so sick i think he has
a green shirt on i think it's a soccer
shirt
but he's a green shirt on i remember um
i don't know why i said that i'm just
trying to
process it in my head um
oh yeah dashboard damn see these
tangents and rants are
terrible here we go so the podcast
i have my note over there but the notes
gone so i wasn't sure what to do
here we go the podcast guys marty and i
are super stoked to say
like we uh i don't know if you heard in
the [ __ ] manscaped ad last week but
we were on a trial room with manscaped
everything did great so thank you guys
for doing the code clicking the links
thank you so much because they just
booked us through the whole end of the
year
[ __ ] awesome we got a whole end of
the year marty should i talk about other
things we have in the works or not
because by the time this comes out
though either going to be yes or no
what do you think what do you think
i think it's important to let the fans
know that there's a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ]
cooking right now and 13 episodes
in i've worked on some of the biggest
podcasts out there and
none of them 13 episodes in had the [ __ ]
that we have cooking right now in terms
of
being able to sustain this and keep it
going through ad partners and stuff like
that
brand deals but uh
yeah it's amazing it's really we're
super grateful and it's like it had to
go like that and we're just super happy
that it did and it's
it feels amazing yes marty gave you the
nice guy thing yo [ __ ] tell them
tell them tell them what's going on who
we're working on some [ __ ] right now we
got manscaped uh locked in for this guys
and we talked to you about stereo
the guy coordinating everything passed
away so we're just waiting on that we're
not to rush them
stereo is the part so you guys know that
just so we're not just like oh yeah
we're taking an ad here and there
give us money that's not what we're
doing the guy [ __ ] died so
please be nice about it and don't rush
anything like yo where the [ __ ] is
that just chill okay but manscape to the
end of the year marty
take it away take it away and you know
who i'm talking about save them save
them for last
let them know what we're doing let them
know what we've been doing this next
coming week
i don't know how much i really want to
put out all right see that's not that's
why i wanted to just let it go to you
i don't know let's let's just say that
i've been in this industry for a long
time now
and i mean we're just working every
connection we have we have the
statistics within our first dozen
episodes to go after
big ass corporations right now because
our numbers right now because of the
fans
are that of a big-time established
podcast but because it's
new that we're in this window of it
being new right now where it's like
these companies want to probably get on
board because they
they see what the potential is and what
it could be and we're super confident in
that so it's like
we're only entertaining deals that are
authentic to thomas and to the show
people that you know we've turned down
deals we've turned down we too
turned down the deal yesterday all the
time yeah so all the [ __ ] time
you know where they would have paid this
yeah we're in this thing for the long
run but
we've been i have been a part of this
before so we
we know what we need to do to sustain it
but the fact that it's all coming
together quickly
we'll see you know right now we got
manscape locked in but
we'll see we'll see what happens so
marty went all the way around that again
and still didn't say any other
time i know we shouldn't talk about him
too much i don't want to say i don't
want i don't want to
say [ __ ] and so they're actually locked
in see that's why i let it go to you
like
i don't i'd never really talk about
things before they're there but let's
just say it guys
it's [ __ ] crazy and badass and
awesome
and if so we'll finally get paid
i know people are like wait you're just
doing for money suck my dick
we put up all the money for everything
it's expensive
rent's not cheap for a warehouse all
right it's
it costs money so yes guys uh marty and
i
thank you thank you we just want to say
thank you thank you because you guys
crush it on these [ __ ] ads
the stuff we the the ads we take you
guys really go do the clicks you guys
are really buying the [ __ ] using our co
it's [ __ ] yeah thank you and shout out
to you
youtube thank you for letting us [ __ ]
advertise in our videos
i know one of you [ __ ] out
there is watching it from youtube thank
you guys
and we want to say thanks stop you know
like demonetizing our videos that'd be
sick but i we still appreciate you guys
letting us be here
and we're going to get that hundred
thousand black soon real soon real
[ __ ] soon so thank you guys
just i mean this is how we parlay this
we the next move is two episodes a week
yep
and then pay-per-view episodes and then
live episodes yes guys we're trying to
do some live shows
the world's opening back up so live
the live podcast oh [ __ ] yeah
that sounds bomb we can legally take
mushrooms if we want on stage and just
get [ __ ] [ __ ] based
could you imagine that oh [ __ ] we'll see
man that that's that's the trajectory
though and we do it through views and
fan support it's the only way that's the
only way this works guys they look at
the numbers and go holy [ __ ] you guys
are doing great like
the fans that's the [ __ ] nine solid
years
our only pitch is our fan support yep
that's how we
do everything our fans are on it our
fans are there we're all
active it's real that's it yeah yeah
we're not creeps we're going to over
deliver every [ __ ] time because
that's what we do
so yeah that's what's going on right now
with the podcast i have the note there
so i just wanted to leave it there
um on to the next thing let's just keep
this move what time are we at right now
40 about 43. okay cool another update
guys we're trying not to do three to
four hour podcast anymore because it
takes marty too long to edit and the
import export
upload time was 32 hours total to upload
the four hour episode
32. it's ridiculous that's ridiculous so
we're trying to cut them back but like i
said we're trying to make it two times a
week but for now
we're trying to make keep them under two
hours hour and a half
two hours we're not trying to do three
even though i can do i'll [ __ ] do 10
hours we'll stay here all day
but we can't do that to ourselves all
right we it's just
it's it's becoming a problem it doesn't
the files the storage it doesn't
work so we're trying to keep it lower
that's why
i want to start talking about the more
my bullet points and not just dragging
and to have themselves at a more
consistent time too yeah two o'clock
every monday instead of like
uploading still still uploading probably
about eight o'clock tonight like that
[ __ ] sucks man
uh it makes this looks it's not that
makes it look stupid i just feel like
i'm not organized enough like why
it's because it's just uploading so long
they're 4k cameras what are the podcasts
you know doing four 4k cameras
switching not doing live switching
cutting and [ __ ] doing intros outros
uh you know i've seen a lot of other
podcasts out there very inspired though
since we dropped
good good step it up that's [ __ ]
awesome and we're not saying like we're
better than you that's never we subtly
wanted to come in and let
show people through our actions that
we're taking our the lookout take it
seriously
yeah yeah we take it serious man
cinematic is what we do if you're a fan
before you know
our videos are [ __ ] commercials or
apple commercials they look
[ __ ] awesome because we take our time
it takes we're going to do things
remember that episode of the south park
was a uh
six days to air i think it's called they
show you from when they get the concept
of the show until it airs on comedy
central
we want to do that to show you how much
time that go
truly it's like how it's made podcast
episode
that's six days of work at six days of
work man it's crazy but it's true but
i'm
we're building the drastic graphics team
out to support it as the podcast grows
which is gonna just let me
focus more yeah so that's where we're at
guys um but like i said for time
purposes and just
for your attention spans i i like i said
i feel like
so yeah what's the nice bullet point
that's how i feel right now but i'm
needing to wake the [ __ ] up
here we go marty is going on a trip next
month guys so we're going to be filming
more episodes to backlog him have him
edited
marty's going on his trip 10-year
anniversary yeah
10-year married anniversary or 10-year
marriage marriage anniversary yeah
can real quick before we get on to
anything can you please please please
please please
tell everyone how you propose to your
wife and no no it's awesome
can you tell them what seinfeld [ __ ]
happened to you
yo guys i can't wait ready ready uh
jasper it wasn't it's a clip
here's a clip go it wasn't that i mean
okay it was very seinfeld ask and that's
what it was it was because all right now
that i really think about it
about it all right first of all april's
aunt had to
basically buy her ring for me which was
like i wasn't gonna be able to get her a
[ __ ] ring
if she didn't help me out with it and
she did which was a huge deal
so we got her this engagement ring from
[ __ ] zales
all right the thing was blinging it was
in a great range thing was blinging
all right her aunt's legit it was a real
ring it wasn't some bootleg [ __ ]
and the [ __ ] diamonds kept falling
out of it
it happened like three i'm like what
three times
multiple times i it turned into a real
situation where i was [ __ ]
freaking out on the people at zells
before you even gave it to her
uh i guess the this is no no no no this
is afterwards this is i'm kind of
venting about this pre
okay about it don't be trying to get
around the phone yeah yeah yeah no i
don't do that
i think about it but yeah that was a
[ __ ] issue but anyway
yeah i thought i was surprising her but
i really wasn't so i booked
listen we're from buffalo buffalo new
york buffalo is a small ass little town
okay we're next to one of the seven
wonders of the world in niagara falls
okay how fast niagara falls okay half
hour real close
so i had her aunt book us
i'm pretty sure i didn't even book it i
was broke as [ __ ] at the time
a hotel at the niagara falls sheridan
little to no it's just next to the
airport [ __ ] buffalo
yo you gotta build it you gotta build
there's not much more
to it in a bong no it's we started
driving to the [ __ ] hotel and i'm
trying to be all mysterious about where
we're going like we're going to niagara
falls and i'm like
we're still in buffalo i got the map
quest going on
already booked a hotel called niagara
falls sheraton because niagara falls is
there
but it's just called that and it's in
buffalo by the airport
you try to do this romantic ass thing
it's mcdowell's we don't have sesame
seeds on our bodies
that's what you just did hold on
continue continue what happened you get
there so we
we had my daughter with us who was
probably two or three at the time
and this i mean literally this this
you're just going to a hotel that's
chill climatic
right she doesn't know your proposal
yeah no she thinks we're just
hanging out going to a hotel to like let
the kids swim in a pool and have an
overnight or some [ __ ]
all right she bought that yeah i mean
yeah like her aunt i mean we used to do
stuff like that once in a while ago okay
okay okay but
yeah so i can kind of like arrange with
this we're just lit now that i think
about it we're in the [ __ ] hotel
restaurant
at the [ __ ] sheridan how many people
are there beside you
one other table of people on just a
random day
too this isn't for a holiday or anything
like
yeah there's one other people it's 12 30
in the afternoon
i arranged with the staff like i was
[ __ ] uh
you know uh would give me a good example
i was gonna say what example you're
gonna use
ironically my mind went to cheaters like
they were like [ __ ]
no no no no no yeah no i arranged with
the staff like
uh ferris bueller you're gonna i don't
know i don't [ __ ] i can't think of
anybody that did some suave
[ __ ] like that besides like double 07.
well well it wasn't too suave because i
had one of the [ __ ] waiters
video it and i don't have the [ __ ]
video
all right on their phone no on my camera
yeah i don't know what happened to that
i'll find it one day yeah it could
but he um you know it was honestly all a
giant blur from the moment that like
homeboy came around with the camera i
think he might have bust out the [ __ ]
ringer or something maybe i don't even
really you never told me this much
i don't even it was honestly a blur i i
got down on one knee i said what i was
gonna say
april's like in her mind she's like
we're in the [ __ ]
hotel restaurant here but i had to at
that point we were too deep like
it was time to [ __ ] no turning back
yeah like i don't care if this is not
the place i thought it was
yeah i'm [ __ ] doing it yeah so we got
a slow
clap from the one table literally
and then we just went back to our meal
and [ __ ]
it's so uneventful just anticlimactic
she just said yeah yeah
right now she just looked around like
whoa this turns weird
i'm sorry this is where i get proposed
to out i guess in life
it's not like april cared it's just
really funny to hear yeah yeah yeah
oh that's [ __ ] great because there
was no it wasn't like here like you
could take somebody to a hotel in l.a
and there's some [ __ ] and have it be a
nice
i know but the fact i i'll like keep
thinking it's like you're like playing
and automobiles have you ever seen that
movie when things just get shittier
like yo map quest
[Laughter]
we're in buffalo they got our names at
the front
this is the place this is the hotel but
it's not in niagara falls
it's not by the 700
yeah and then so uh our actual first
trip to niagara falls
i tried to surprise her with a trip to
the actual falls for like her
birthday and i kept having this string
of events where i would try to plan
something and then somebody would
[ __ ] blow it for me
oh yeah the moment before it happened
like probably five or six times
so like bam that happened you know that
we as soon as we get there
we get stuck in the elevator for like an
hour just mid elevator just stuck you're
you don't watch time oh yeah of course
okay because you sound like
you sound like your life is seinfeld i
don't know i'm just kind of highlighting
the low lights here i'll
ride in sick what kind of pants you got
on right now
some honeydew pants i see them yeah
but uh the thing about niagara falls is
the funny part i don't know if i told
you this
yeah you got niagara falls buffalo
ghetto as [ __ ] and then you got niagara
falls canada which is like a clean
little vegas
so what we were on i didn't realize that
either
you're from there you know that no we
don't you don't inherently know about
niagara falls if you're from buffalo
i would i assumed as a human that
niagara falls in new york had
some commerce built up around the
[ __ ] commerce
there's might have changed at this point
but there was one hotel
there was one hotel and you got one side
facing the falls and you got
one side facing the [ __ ] hood was it
a house
no i'm talking about the hotel was it a
house but it was made into a hotel no it
was a legit this was uh
okay native american owned casino hotel
oh [ __ ] pretty good yeah yeah yeah it
was sick man [ __ ] i thought i was
balling and being at the [ __ ] hotel
are you guys tall teon yeah yeah this
place is this place is cruel
what else are you saying like 2007 i
don't know i probably nailed it probably
nailed it yeah
it's crunk i know you do i know you do i
love it
um so that's what happened to marty it
was [ __ ]
the first thing he told me that story
was amazing so yeah
um but anyway 10-year anniversary coming
up we're going to goddamn hawaii
yeah going to hawaii he's going to
mother
so that's why we're gonna do some more
episodes so when he's gone we could be
posting premiering
doing everything shout out to deanna
cause she's about to take over when
you're going
[ __ ] yeah well i knew she could when she
held the fourth down while i was filming
not a sports show
six days in a row she [ __ ] held the
fourth down i'm like all right you're on
it
good [ __ ] drop by fire guys as i said
earlier i'm on heroin um i'm trying to
keep this
not like someone snacks i i feel it i
don't know why but i feel it i'm trying
my best
do you guys remember when i talked about
in one of the podcast episodes where the
dentist
shaved my [ __ ] teeth and then the
machine broke
so he had to use a manual version of it
marty can you bring up that beautiful
bean footage so you guys ready here this
is what you're watching that's what they
were using on my tooth and there it is
there's the mini sauce can you back it
up a little bit back it up a little bit
honey you remember they did all of the
fronts of my teeth top and bottom
and he broke the thing broke two teeth
in like like one or two teeth in
you just keep looping it keep looping it
i'm telling you bro keep looping that
part
that's what they did to me guys i
[ __ ] saw this on tick-tock and go no
way
this is a video of what they did to my
teeth all i did
was try to not grind my teeth that's
what i got invisalign for because i
grabbed my teeth
and they're over here doing this to me
guys that's what they did to me
i finally found it all right i found a
video to show you what i mean by a
miniature saw
that [ __ ] was medieval and that's what
they did i didn't think
manual sawing of teeth was just standard
one or even just [ __ ] just
that was the worst that [ __ ] hurts
man
because they have to hit your gums if
you notice they were on her gum her
gum's red as [ __ ] right there
so on to the next thing i wanted to show
you guys that if you haven't seen it
it's called the dentist shaved my teeth
go check out
right here dope as usual podcast clips
channel there it is we just hit 22 000
this morning you guys are [ __ ]
awesome
thank you um can you go to the next link
guys i do you guys know this i do
something called story time
on the dopaziola channel and i did
something called deals gone wrong i did
that a couple months ago marty i don't
know how
it's only a few months old it's already
at 1.5 million i noticed that
what the [ __ ] you guys are the [ __ ]
thank you so much
in there a lot of my stories i get
people talking [ __ ] and like you know
it's fake
i don't give a [ __ ] you guys ready
i told a story about um
it's um jill's gone wrong and it's about
yo did i tell it on the podcast the most
sophisticated drug dealer ever
the podcast about the uh about excel
okay i think i did talk about the
podcast
where i talked about where i went to
this i met this dealer and he had
like 10 000 pounds plus on hand
like dope [ __ ] craziest things i've ever
seen dopest prices ever
and i said it was like a like an old
what did i say old grocery store
in the middle of a town it was like a
grocery store huge [ __ ] building
and it was like a drug superstore you
just go in and get anything you want
marty can you play back that
[ __ ] clip real quick
can you keep playing like that clip no
no this clip just started from the
beginning
oh you need to refresh the page refresh
the page
[Music]
i don't want to get us in trouble
because there's music right there you
see that giant building
yeah the voiceover on the [ __ ] news
31 people got arrested right here
they had that building and they called
it a drug super center
that's what the cops called it when they
walked in that huge building was
all drugged out that's like if you
knocked out these walls
yep and started just loading it up with
safes
metal walls and started putting hundreds
of thousands of pounds in there
that's what these guys were doing that's
what that's about i like when i was
trying to tell you guys like yo that's
fake
yo it's not fake and that's not the only
one and that's not the one i went to
i don't even know where fulton is i've
never been there but
it's norris county is it oh well that
one's in orange county guys
i've never been there but the one i'm
talking about is nowhere near here
but uh they're real and i was trying to
explain to you guys like no
it's real i've been to one other place
kind of like that
and um yeah deal's gone wrong that's on
the dobaziola channel if you want to
watch that
that's what i was talking about that's
what i was referring to guys this is it
large drug bust there it is um can you
bring up my [ __ ] notes real
quick
here we go so i got those done deal's
gone wrong that's what i was talking
about
i gotta tell you guys a small story real
quick real small story all right it's
probably gonna take forever
[ __ ] let me try to be more precise let
me get to the story let me tell you it
all
get inside my brain real quick seinfeld
larry david [ __ ] this is kirby
enthusiasm
mixed with some [ __ ] you're
channeling a lot of [ __ ] right now i see
it
thinking of it all like i'm just trying
to like you remember in the mask
where uh at the end uh what is his name
dario
dorian marty i love you so much for
knowing his [ __ ] name right now i
love you so
much right you can count on me for that
oh
dorian yes thank you that's his name
remember at the end why all of that just
to reference what you said are you just
channeling things
acid mom thanks that's my brain just
working ready
remember at the end when they shoot the
[ __ ] and he goes
that's how i get ready for stories i
just go ah what is it all right aaron
what else do you do okay all right
story time intro and you just see like a
bunch of memories like little [ __ ]
enemies here and then i was like this oh
that's amazing don't do that to me if we
can't do that what do you mean if we
can't do that
how do we do that how do you how do you
do that on editing you hire people that
can do that [ __ ]
so yeah uh yo netflix
come on get with the program sorry
shafir had that [ __ ] going
get the program um okay okay
give me the [ __ ] program give us some
money and give us the show all right
we're just gonna [ __ ] come out and
ask for that i'll tell you what
you're gonna say right now right nephew
let's throw some stats we did the stats
the other day story time
54 episodes 40 plus million
[ __ ] views 1.5 million thumbs ups on
these
series 40 million views on my series
it's only 54 episodes
are you guys ready all of that number
while being shadow band
i'm shadow band to death on youtube
shadow band means they don't show your
page to anybody they just have to type
your name in
to see it so imagine if it wasn't shadow
man marty
yeah 100 million views yeah wow
it's [ __ ] amazing so and i know it's
not like you you sound like a cocky
[ __ ]
[ __ ] you man i'm just saying the numbers
for netflix to go wow he's very
confident yeah come on man numbers are
numbers
is all that anybody cares about these
companies
hundreds of thousands of millions of
dollars to get these numbers and a lot
of them
it's not easy to do even when you throw
that much [ __ ] money at it yeah you
can throw superstars and money all the
[ __ ] story time on netflix and people
would watch them
of course sophia that's a given a little
bit production money
it takes one camera some time
netflix what are you doing yeah no the
quality that it's at right now is ready
it's ready to go it's actually approved
that's the
his camera is right it's like ready so
that's an approved camera we're netflix
ready but yeah so how do we get on that
topic
cameron diaz i'm sorry i always say like
i think she got her body
switched out after that movie because
she was something different going on she
didn't look the same after she looked
like jessica rabbit and then
to normal cameron diaz which is still
hella pretty yeah i'm just saying
she went from car show model to like
yoga teacher
and i'm not [ __ ] lying and i'm not
bending the truth
here we go let me tell you about this
story
real quick a small story is a it's a
quick story i hope
ready i gotta take it all
ready go last year i bought uh imac
27-inch imac i spent like 2 300 bucks on
it i was like damn that's a lot of
[ __ ] money
that's a pound of weed [ __ ] here we go
bought it love it super slow it's super
slow when i edit it's [ __ ] give me
the spinning wheel with the [ __ ]
rainbow [ __ ] the rainbow reel anyway i
talked marty i talked to charlie they're
both computer guys they suggested i get
the new
um if i want to stick with mac i get the
m the
13-inch macbook with the m1 chip yeah
yeah with the m1 chip correct
you ran back correct yes so um
i got it this is what i did you ready
for my story my larry david [ __ ] are
you guys [ __ ] ready this is
i know it's so miniscule and it's not
that big of a deal it's just like
these things happen every day though
every day to me and i tell you about
them and go
you wouldn't ever believe what just
happened to me no no it happened
completely real i called you twice that
day because i thought i got it fixed and
then went
hey no you facetimed me from from the
apple store
is ready so i pick up my [ __ ]
computer and i walk uh
i get out of my car go to the mall i
pick up my [ __ ] computer i go to the
well i think it's a glenda mall the
glenda gallery i go to glenda galleria
park my [ __ ] car take my macbook i'm
walking my macbook from the parking lot
to the elevator
for some reason and i know this is
stupid that's small but hold on you're
talking about your giant imac right it's
heavy you're calling it a macbook
oh sorry imac uh desktop got the 27-inch
the big-ass one yeah so it's not like
it's pretty [ __ ] heavy it's just
these corners are sharp and i was
thinking am i that much of a [ __ ] but
this just kind of hurts yeah no you need
a case to carry that okay so
i'm there and i'm waiting about eight
minutes
for the elevator and there's an
escalator right there and there's stairs
i'm like
i'm lazy i'm not gonna do it i'm gonna
do it it's gonna come open those doors
gonna open i know they are
so i'm sitting there just regretting
like i could have been downstairs
already so that's how my [ __ ] started
off me
procrastinating and being a lazy [ __ ]
so i finally get in the elevator
i go down i go to the i called the apple
store and asked if they let me do it
if they let me go and trade my computer
in they're only gonna give me 730 bucks
it's eight months old
i paid 2200 for it so i was gonna say
[ __ ] i'll take the loss and get the new
macbook cause i need something that's to
work with the m1 ship
sorry i know the story is [ __ ]
getting slow here we go
so i go to the [ __ ] store go to the
apple store in the [ __ ]
nexus glenda gallery at the americana
right and i go hey man i'm here with the
thing he goes what are you talking about
we don't take that we don't do trade in
here go
yeah i just talked to you man and he
goes no you didn't i'm like
oh yeah [ __ ] you all right here we go
[ __ ]
where is my appointment oh no i go you
told me not to make an appointment you
said just to walk in
and he goes we would never say that you
just so i'm already like holding this
thing going
but you told me not to make an
appointment you said to walk in it's not
busy
it's nope not me and then he goes i
think you're at the wrong apple store
there's only one apple store he goes nah
there's one in the mall too
go [ __ ] it's on the same street
yep of course it's not that one but you
guys you guys know the americana to the
other side of the mall where target's at
if you know what i'm talking about it's
like
three or four hundred yards to get to
the door and then you have to find it in
the mall and that mall is two to three
blocks long
so i know it's like you're lazy you
can't walk you gotta remember
the [ __ ] irritation so i go back to
the elevator
and there is a [ __ ] line so i can go
back to my car and drive those two three
blocks i'm not gonna carry my [ __ ]
computer
so i go to the elevator and there's a
[ __ ] line
i mean a line and i'm looking at all
these people
like wow i am just going to take the
escalator because i can't get back up
the stair i mean there was no stairs
sorry there was an escalator and there
was an elevated stairs earlier
anyway damn this [ __ ] story just
getting all out of hand
ready i go to the escalator and the
escalators are blocked off
because there's maintenance because
they're broken can't take the escalator
can't get in the elevator can't get to
my car
marty i can now not get to my car
physically
okay so i can't get my car unless i walk
around the entire block and start
walking up
each driveway of the [ __ ] parkade
with a macbook in my hand this is this
is [ __ ] that happens when you have kids
just say you know
okay so if i had kids on top of that
i'd be losing my mind yeah so me and
rosie i'm looking at like
of course of course the escalators are
blocked off
can't use it they wanna they weren't
blocked off marty when i got out of the
elevator to the apple store
by the time i walked to the apple store
and came back
the maintenance people blocked them off
two minutes i just missed a minute so
i'm like
of course the maintenance guys came
while i went to the wrong apple store
for three [ __ ] solid minutes talked
to the guy and left
came back and went uh okay so my car's
up there
can't get to it unless i want to wait
for all these elevated people and i'm
not and it took me 10 minutes to [ __ ]
get my own elevator and it's covered yes
and i don't want to be around all these
people i have to go to the mall to begin
with i don't want to go to the [ __ ]
mall
anyway here we go guys sorry let's get
this [ __ ] story rolling so i say
rosie
we now have to walk this [ __ ] macbook
i mean mac uh imac
to the apple store and she goes of
course we do oh yep
let's go so i start walking i walk all
the way to the apple store
i get there right i talk to the guy and
i go hey you told me not to make an
appointment to come in he goes
we would never say that and i just put
my head down again and i go
dude i just walked this computer over
here to trade it in you guys said you
have it in stock oh i don't even think
we have stock
and i'm like i'm [ __ ] throw up all
over your [ __ ] shoes right now dude
tell me right now i was like nah man
i walked this over you you told me to
you told me i got kind of upset i'm like
you told me to bring you here i'm here
you told me not to make an appointment
and he goes let me see what i can do and
he walks away talks to his manager and
he [ __ ]
lets me in the store perfectly normal
like what you couldn't just done in the
beginning anyway i get in there and the
guy that's helping me the mac
genius was obviously high coolest white
dude with a beard
very cool he looked like he would read
uh children's books to kids
nice kind of guy you know so
weren't we mid video edit wasn't there
something frantic going on that has you
pissed off prior to all this yeah cause
my videos kept crashing someone goes i'm
getting a new computer right now [ __ ]
this i don't plug this [ __ ] called
i imagine this is [ __ ] so that's why
i had
i was in a rush and i had to get the
video off yeah there was some sense of
urgency
[Music]
that's why i'm like oh [ __ ] you and uh
so i get there and i'm like yo i want to
trade this
in he goes i can do that for you okay i
want to get this one
i asked if you had in stock i have it in
stock
thank you sir i gave him my macbook we
erased it he gave it to me i paid the
difference and i go can i get insurance
and he goes yes
puts my laptop in a bag hands it to me
with my receipt and i go thank you
i've never had anything work out the way
it's supposed to
ever with technology you know this you
know this you're taking the win on just
the back half
just the experience i just lost fourteen
hundred dollars
off of my own computer and i'm like
thank you because i take that loss over
i sat there for four hours because my
credit card was declined because
somebody [ __ ] stole my identity like
something always happens to me so i go
thanks man i looked at rosie you know
this is
[ __ ] awesome and i go thank you for
real because man no problem have a good
day
go here [ __ ] yeah and i walked out as
i'm walking out like
no there's no there's no [ __ ] way in
hell this is real
i look in it and it's the wrong [ __ ]
macbook
it's the wrong macbook he charged me for
the super expensive one and gave me the
wrong
one right so i go hey man this is the
wrong one he goes oh good thing you
check and go oh thank god i checked i
didn't even leave the store i looked at
rosie
at least we didn't go home and like i
set my [ __ ] up because i'm happy now
we're in the store let's get a new one
let's get the right one
and he comes back five seconds later
we're actually out of stock kind of like
going
no but you said you had stock in it and
he goes but i don't have it
and i go well what about my computer he
goes
they're probably erasing it right now i
can go get him stop
all my all my programs i'm just thinking
like oh my god okay
um can you go see if you guys have this
oh what about another one so i was like
what about the
one up from that so i said [ __ ] it that
was expensive what about the more
expensive one do you have the more
expensive i just need one that with the
chip
so i can [ __ ] edit this is the fear
that's going through my [ __ ] brain
right now
he takes me to the side and goes we do
have it in stock i'll be right back
well thank god no he says i'll have him
bring it out and a guy brings it out
as he brings it out it's the wrong one
again
what the [ __ ] the wrong one again he
goes oh bro this is not the one
and he as he's ringing me up again i go
this is the wrong one again
he just looks down like oh my god it's
like the wrong ram right
the wrong ram it's a big i don't even
know what that is but yes
it's the wrong stuff the wrong juice and
uh that's the other thing you don't even
know i don't know what any of it is i
asked you like what's the gb
the gigabytes need to be what's the ram
need to be
thanks that's how i feel with
technologies guys so i know something
always goes wrong so i'm standing there
and he goes
[ __ ] dude we're out of stock he starts
looking on his little ipad
they're out of stock in l.a they're out
of stock from california
right weeks back ordered ready
and he goes i'm gonna see if i can get
any store that has any in stock he
searches every [ __ ] store on their
dad
he goes we don't have any and i'm just
like stressing i'm already facetimed you
i have already facetimed marty and told
him the situation
and i'm just sitting there stressing out
like oh my god
what am i gonna do and i go hey
how about you just give me my money i'll
just trade the macbook in
i'll trade my my imac in you can keep
the imac
i'm going to buy the computer look at
this what happened
apple didn't have it so i went i had
rosie go on [ __ ] amazon and she found
it my exact macbook
right she found it except what happened
guys
i traded my computer in already they
can't give me cash back
they said i can only get store credit
[Laughter]
said i can only get store credit guys
i traded my whole computer in at a loss
and then when they couldn't refund me
because they didn't have what i wanted
they could only give me store credit
the macbook didn't show up for ford it
said four days whoa
so now i'm four days late i don't have
any computer i have no computer
i lost fourteen hundred dollars i got
seven hundred thirty dollars for my
trade-in and i can only use that apple
there's literally nothing we need from
apple right now
and then and then what happened i bought
it on amazon
i can't use my apple my apple
so guys i know that was a long story but
that's what happened to me i'm just
trying to get a [ __ ] seinfeld
guys all i wanted to do was get a new
computer and pay for it give him
currency
from america and then they go nah
he only gets starbucks guard that's
basically what they did we'll give you a
gift card
and i told the guy can i just get my
gift card i'll keep it and use it
some way and then i'm just going to
leave your store
and you can keep my computer and then i
find out that i need to get my mouse on
my lap my keyboard
he was oh man yeah people just don't
bring this
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you can i just do it
without the stuff then i felt so played
because he was so nice i'm like yeah
thanks and it turned into an hour and a
half of me going oh [ __ ] would i do what
i do
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] no computer so i had no
computer for four days
you had like just signed like a new deal
or something i just signed a new
contract with somebody
and i was working on the video for him
well and then seinfeld yeah seinfeld
we had another sad technological moment
again today
i filmed an entire vlog yesterday yeah
there is no seinfeld moment in this
though
i filmed a whole vlog files are
corrupted
you know i'm not lying when i say
technology technology is stupid
sometimes cameras just really just want
you to like they want to they want to
[ __ ]
me you see it all the time but yeah
anyway
all my files are corrupted that's the
apple story that's the story i have
at apple and i even wrote in my notes my
life is seinfeld
it says it right there in my notes jesus
[ __ ] christ
what time are we at because i feel like
i just ranted for hours what time 1 15.
oh good guys brings me into my neck top
my next topic
let's wake up let's wake up a little bit
all right ah
let's wake up here we go one of our
official sponsors is manscaped right now
if you click the link in our description
or you go to manscape.com
yola you'll get 20 off and you'll get
free shipping on anything on the whole
order if you buy one thing it's still
20 off free shipping so for those of you
that are new to manscape which i [ __ ]
doubt
manscaped is a grooming tool well
they're grooming tools it's a [ __ ]
brand there's a lot of things and yes if
you're watching and paying attention
real closely the bag to my left yes this
bag right here says ball wipes
yes they are ph balanced ball wipes the
thing i love about manscaped is even
when they send us all this like talking
points and stuff
some of them are [ __ ] hilarious i
read them often just like
yo who the [ __ ] wrote this [ __ ]
in the best way possible i think one of
them said
don't use the same razor you use on your
on your balls that use you for your face
that's just gross or you don't want
pubes in your mouth do you
like yo whoever wrote this needs to be
my [ __ ] friend
so it's a big reason why we really love
teaming up with manscape you guys thank
you so much but once again guys if you
go to manscape.com
yolo or you click the link in our
description the link's always in the
video description or if you're on
spotify apple it's
always in the video description that
will give you 20 off
but you got to click our link if you
don't click our link you don't get the
discount it will say you'll see it says
it right there brought to you by
dope as usual podcast so with that code
you'll get 20 off and free shipping it's
a win-win situation all the way around
once again guys 100 authentic ad read
the manscaped
4.0 lawnmower actually works i was
expecting blood and there was no blood
it's scary as [ __ ] shaving your dick and
balls is [ __ ] scary if you're a guy
you know exactly what i'm talking about
it's [ __ ] scary this has a light on
it it will not cut you doesn't pinch you
i
i didn't try to cut my [ __ ] nick but
i
definitely didn't do super careful in
case i'm like yo i love man's gate
but you know two months later cut a
[ __ ] hole in my balls so
that's why i had to use it make sure it
worked it works guys and it's [ __ ]
waterproof
again thank you to our sponsor manscaped
back to the episode
this is uh i'm gonna introduce this
right now i'm gonna tell you guys a
little story here's a little story time
i'm gonna tell you guys a story i um
told this it's called i think it's
called magic mushrooms it's
i did it in season one of story time i'm
gonna tell you guys a story about
mushrooms
and to bring up before i brought up
mushrooms me i went them to the mall
of all places i went to the mall i went
to that very same mall today with my
friend
and went to one store and there was like
40 [ __ ] mushroom t-shirts
all over about 20. a lot everyone's
selling mushroom apparel and [ __ ] right
now everyone's like
finally [ __ ] with shrooms i like that
i like that people are finally open
their eyes
because mushrooms are [ __ ] fun so
here we go guys
let's get into this story and like i
said i'm trying to keep this shorter so
i'm gonna i'm gonna
talk about one more thing after the
story but the story is pretty
[ __ ] intense and the best part about
it is if you've been following me for a
long time
you're gonna remember what this is and
you're gonna remember the time i talked
about it
when it happened so ready i'm gonna skip
all the pre-intro stuff because
i don't like that person anymore so i
won't even talk about it here we go
oh you now
it is time oh we got to get bruce buffer
to go
story time oh my god he'll do it on
camera
that's cool i like that here we go
this story time let's just call it
mushrooms in washington
hello washington yes sick that would be
it's time
now story time story time
oh my god dope
oh has god and then i come and just
knock knock somebody unconscious oh
i'll be sick i'm kidding all right here
we go mushrooms
mushrooms in washington here we go guys
here we go here we go so i went to this
event
in north west of america
all right it was right before the
canadian border i mean
15 minutes before the canadian border
i go to this event it's a weed event and
it was whatever i'd you know it's a weed
event so all day chilling doing the weed
[ __ ]
cool this event was in a huge huge
field i i don't know house to call it
was a field
and then all around the field was forest
it's like somebody cut all the trees
down in this one like
five acre patch it was huge there was a
lot of land right
so guys uh this is like my second year
of doing instagram so i'm still
fairly new to it i have a really big
following at the time still but i'm not
having been
you know not even moved to l.a yet
pushed trees i don't think it was
started yet
it might have been but i'm not sure so
here we go
so i was in washington right and i did
this event right fast forward bam
events going on over toward the other
night
apparently in washington at night
everyone's just a psychedelic so cool
and i'm out in the country i mean not
the country i'm out in the woods
right there's a bunch of people set up
tents cars
we're in the middle of the forest though
we had to drive down a really long dirt
road to get there
so a gravel road so we're there
and this guy i know has
mushrooms and i'm like yeah i love
mushrooms
i will eat them he walks up to me and
says hey i got all these mushrooms i
look at them like those look dry
but okay i trust your opinion yes let me
get some and he hands me like
two handfuls right if you're at home he
hands me like if you're trying to
cup water in your hand and not let it
fall out with two hands that's how much
mushrooms gave me all right
just about that much is that a good
comparison it seems like a lot of
[ __ ] mushrooms
i mean not just for me it was for me
like rosie and my other friends okay
it's like yo you guys hang out because
we were all hanging out we're staying at
a hotel about two miles away
but the whole event was 24 hours people
were camping out how much do mushrooms
cost though like how much is that worth
an eight goes straight straight for
about 25 bucks
cheaper than weed way cheaper than weed
mushrooms are way cheaper than wheat a
pound's like 1700
1800 bucks that doesn't add up to me
yeah huh
yeah all right you can't really do
mushrooms every day
no i'm still eating less weight they're
illegal they're more
they're legal they're legal in oakland
bro
you can go buy legal [ __ ] mushrooms
right now and i knew about colorado i
mean oakland
yeah okay all right okay another place
in california legal
you can go to a shop i think uh there's
a shop in oakland you can go and get
[ __ ] mushrooms
with strains and [ __ ] like amsterdam
and it's and it's that cheap those might
be different i'm not sure
but i know this guy that makes mushroom
bars they're like 35
wholesale but they're in chocolate bars
they're like wonka bars all rap
nutrition facts
sick [ __ ] designs it's pretty cool but
um
so yes he gives me a bunch of mushrooms
but in washington he grabbed no he
grabbed him out of a pound bag though
marty so it didn't really matter he just
went
out of the bag and goes bam oh those
look dry that's all i thought like
all right here we go and then i ate i
ate like
an eighth rosy eight like an eighth my
friend on eight and eight
so remember this is at the it's there's
no stadium lights
there's no it's it's a [ __ ] forest
it's a forest
and but they're like edc kind of kids so
they got like
cool light show going and like there's
people dancing and on the sides all the
weed stuff
and there's a stage where people were
performing right like rappers and [ __ ]
like that it was a weed event
well but it's a long time ago anyway
we're in the forest
and remember like i said there's a big
patch of no trees but on the sides of us
like 200 yards away on the sides
is the forest starting and then there's
like 500 yards in front of us
open space so you see a bunch of like
hippie chicks dancing around all [ __ ]
on
acid and [ __ ] like they're just having a
good time it's night time so
everyone's just chilling we eat the
shrooms and go yo
i've never eaten shrooms in like a
forest can we walk to the forest
okay so we walk toward the forest
and i go we're about 30 yards before the
the trees
and for some reason i go hey do you guys
want to just lay down right here for a
minute
because i don't know if you've ever been
to washington there's no
uh what's called light pollution yeah
you can see the stars i mean the stars
are
right in front of you and i'm looking up
and all i see is tall
trees hell of lights in the distance and
like music bumping
you see people backlit and [ __ ] like way
in the distance it reminds me of a push
trees design didn't you do something
like
the box art with all the push like
you're laying on the ground all the
trees coming up that's what it's
reminding me of
that is not released okay
yep um yeah
yes but yes um so we're laying there
and i'm sitting there and i'm expecting
the mushrooms to hit we waited like 20
minutes but i'm expecting some
kind of feeling so i'm sitting there
laying there
it's me rosie and my friend and he's on
the edge i'm on the edge i think rosie's
next to me i can't remember i remember
there's somebody next to me on my left
we're just laying on a [ __ ] in a
field
looking straight up looking at these
stars waiting for these mushrooms to
kick
in and i'm just sitting you know when
you want your drugs to work you're like
wait i think i feel i think they're
working like i'm because for mushrooms
sometimes they're hitting miss so i'm
sitting there like
no no they're not working okay cool
we're just laying here all right [ __ ] it
so we're sitting there and i sit up
we're there like 35 40 minutes sitting
there waiting for these to work
so guys
in my head you're in my brain i'm
sitting up you know you can see your
feet poking up
you know imagine that you see your feet
people next to you sitting there we're
all just chilling there's no one within
[ __ ]
100 yards of us we're by the way by the
trees the wheat event is about 300 yards
back
what i'm saying but we could see it we
can hear the music
in the back and [ __ ] you see all the fog
lights and [ __ ] it's it's cool
there's a bunch of people out still
they're camping you see a bunch of tents
you see the cars with their headlights
on i'm trying to paint this picture for
you
i'm just looking up and the moon is
above the trees
this way so if somebody was in like
walking through the forest
they'd be somewhat backlit so you would
be able to see their silhouette you see
what i'm saying
so like on some uh x-files [ __ ] like
what is that you know with the light
behind them so
i'm laying there i mean i'm sitting
there my feet up i'm looking and i go
guys ready are you guys [ __ ] ready
for this
i'm looking i'm like is that a person
and i see like way off in the [ __ ]
distance i mean
we're 30 40 yards away from the tree
line
so i can i can see the trees well
they're right there they're huge
but way in the distance i'm like you
know you can see movement so i'm like
what is that is that an animal
i don't have a knife holy [ __ ] is that a
[ __ ] animal
and then i think no it's a dude he's
standing up so i see something walking
standing up
and i'm like is that shaped like a bear
and the first thing i think is is there
a [ __ ] bear
right here i'm gonna start sprinting to
the people because i can't
we no we're gonna get eaten we're gonna
eat we're the only ones out there trying
to trip by ourselves on mushrooms right
so of course we're gonna [ __ ] we're
gonna die
if this is a movie we're dead if that's
a bear
so i just see oh [ __ ] my [ __ ] joke
went out hold on
and i'm like this yo guys guys guys do
you see somebody walking
and remember the light is kind of
backlighting it's almost like it's foggy
like it's very eerie like sasquatch yeah
like some sasquatch [ __ ]
and i'm looking i'm like what is that
remember
mushrooms have been eaten you were
wondering if you were tripping at the
time right okay mushrooms have been
eaten so i'm thinking
in my head nah i think these mushrooms
hit me
and i'm still looking i'm like and then
that's why i got everybody rosie and my
friend looking we're looking like
no no they go oh i see i see it too and
something's walking between the trees
like what the [ __ ] and it comes out
comes out the trees and remember
i can't see it what it is but it looks
like a bear
but walking like a person
the [ __ ] is some bigfoot [ __ ] it's
walking closer
it's you guys are just standing you guys
are we're sitting just like this
just being still it's not right next to
us it's pretty far still
but it's walking i go it's a dude in a
bear suit
cause we're at a festival like it's a
guy in a bear suit
and i tell him like oh my god it's a
[ __ ] dude in a bear suit because you
can see white like he's in a panda's
outfit
like you could see it when he's starting
to come close because the moonlight is
like it's
i can still i can see him more now than
when he was [ __ ] 80 yards away from
me right
and he's getting closer and i'm like
don't say nothing to him
but he's walking like 15 20 feet away
from us but being the bee lining to the
festival
he's probably in the [ __ ] woods
taking a [ __ ] or something weird or
something right
okay so i'm like oh this is a guy but
the whole time thinking
are we all hallucinating this or is
there really a man in a [ __ ] panda
out
i wasn't sure yet but i was pretty
convinced that i wasn't work i wasn't
tripping
are you guys ready are you ready i'm not
even done are you ready for what happens
you ready here we go for everyone in the
car sorry i just had to look at each
camera to get them all ready all you
cameras ready ready
here we go this [ __ ] is about 15
yards 15 feet away from us be
lining like i said not coming toward us
we're sitting here and he's walking from
the woods he walks around us
all right not gonna walk right next to
us like a creep this [ __ ] starts
walking around us
we're sitting in grass i mean we're
sitting in a field so it's like grass
i swear to god i'm so happy that people
were with me because nobody would
believe me in my life nobody would ever
[ __ ] believe me
yo okay so i think my mushrooms are
hitting me now right so
this was walking and i swear to god out
of nowhere out of [ __ ] nowhere no
like
hey what is that nothing he just walking
to this
to automatically walking to boom
flashlights in our face
like a cop quick as [ __ ] but are you
guys ready
the second he goes he's about 15 feet
away from us flashlights in our face
ready he goes are you dope is yola
and i go huh
are you doing zola yeah
y'all love your videos man have a good
night thanks man
and he walked away and i looked at rosie
my homie go you
you guys saw it too right he did say
that right
yeah what the f and we all just started
talking and dying laughing like yo
what the [ __ ] was he in a panda suit he
was in a panda suit
in a full outfit panacea with just his
face exposed
is it that it wasn't there a dude in a
panda suit in one of the vlogs
in the first vlog we did there was a
dude in uh some sort of animal suit that
was wilfred man
okay the tv show
yeah he's cool but no that was a dog
suit no this guy was in a full panda
suit a huge suit of a panda so you're in
the
what you're saying empty field trip
empty field trying to get your balls
in a panda suit in a panda outfit marty
no no not even that the fact that he's
just walking casually goes
so he so he saw me because the
moonlight's behind him we can't see his
face
moonlight's lit light in our faces up
you see what i'm saying sitting there
we're sitting there going
like all right what the [ __ ] and we
realized the guy then he's just as he's
getting
back by us just goes like he was trying
to frighten us just
are you dope yola i go ah i swear to god
bro
i swear to god what happened five
minutes later i go yo these mushrooms
[ __ ] suck
walked back to the [ __ ] place
mushrooms did not hit me
at all then we're walking back to the
cars
i'm driving the hotel i'm not even
tripping [ __ ] this i don't give a [ __ ]
don't drive the mushrooms
and i'm driving and i'm like [ __ ] this
so we start going back through the
the festival and then we come across oh
i see rosie's face hey rosie do you
remember the guy with the puppets
oh yeah see your face see your face
marty ready
there was a guy we were walking back to
our car it's the last like
booth and there's a guy doing a puppet
show but marionettes like with strings
and they're like dolls i think you were
tripping your [ __ ] balls
off we weren't we weren't you ready
he's doing a whole he's got a little
stage like five as big as his table
and he's got like six things going on at
once and they have like a background
and he's playing [ __ ] music
while doing the puppets
you understand what i'm saying he's got
him attached to like his foot and his
hand
so he's moving the strings while he's
playing like a banjo and he's doing [ __ ]
and he's talking and singing
but the [ __ ] he was singing marty made
me
instantly the mushrooms hit me
immediately they went from not hitting
me whatsoever
a dud about to drive home to the worst
trip i've had that's something i don't
understand
i got stuck in a really bad trip looking
at this man and i got like
paralyzed and i couldn't leave and
rosie's next to me and i'm like rosie
rosie rosie rose you want to leave you
want another thing yeah
yeah yeah yeah i want to leave yeah i
get her in her voice like
i don't like this i don't like this i
don't like this guy scary and the guy's
vibe that came off was like
i know you're [ __ ] tripping and i'm
going to be in your brain like he was
looking at us
but he looked nice but the way he was
looking nice was like
maniacal uh-huh but he's doing all this
[ __ ] and like singing all
sick sounds like some american horror
story but he's singing like
to like soothing [ __ ] like he's trying
to draw and there was like 10 people
watching him just
it's like he was putting a spell on us i
swear to god
it was the creepiest thing i've ever
experienced in person because me and
rosie both went
well i don't want to be here but why are
we leaving do you think he was really
super creepy or do you think mushrooms
tunes you in definitely super creepy
he was definitely super creepy but it's
like the mushrooms hit me
and just gave me a bad trip i was stuck
and i could see the puppets and i could
see him closer
and it was like they were getting bigger
on me and i'm like
oh [ __ ] it's like a fun house mirror
yeah
like i was getting funhouse mirror with
them but not like insane but just enough
to where it's like this
and you can notice the difference like
super mario with the mushroom
like not a huge difference but enough
and um
i got stuck for about 10 15 minutes
scared
i broke it once and started walking away
and i got rosy and i started watching it
again
like it's so interesting it was like a
play with these puppets but he's playing
music
and one of them was getting stabbed by
one of the
it was so [ __ ] weird and like
dramatic
anyway that's the time the guy in the
panda suit just was like a fan
and then you know what's crazy i saw two
years ago
there's this group i don't know if you
can google it there was this group going
around in panda suits
murdering people in the forest look it
up
look at remember rosie remember there's
a group of dudes and panda outfits
and they were killing and torturing
people in the forest
they got caught
panda outfits murder forest
panda outfits murder forest
but guys in panda suits commit murder i
saw it a couple years later and people
even said yo your story time
what if he wasn't a fan he would have
killed you guys
because he was [ __ ] scary he was very
he was like
he was a big [ __ ] dude he was a
big ass dude
wait it's not popping up it was in the
news
it was in the [ __ ] news man panda
suits are kind of [ __ ] terrifying
yeah except his had a face cut out you
can see his face
you know i can't it's not there rosie i
saw the [ __ ] on i saw it on the news
and that's when i even said somebody
sent it to me on dm too but uh
yeah anyway guys that was the the
mushroom store that's one of the
mushrooms
and it's not even like a mushroom trip
it's just the fact that i was in the
forest and this guy was a fan
and a panda suit and thing is we're in
the pitch black
so he was like i think it's him let me
shine my [ __ ] light in his face
[ __ ] crazy dude that's
ridiculous it was kind of funny though
uh so yeah that's a small story i just
want to give you one little small story
time all right
and um yeah we're at an hour and a half
i want to do something
me and marty are thinking uh trying to
think of ways to incorporate
fans more whether it's on instagram
youtube whatever but
this time we're trying to lean more
toward patreon people
here we go so our patreons links in the
description
i went and picked uh one question to
answer
me and marty were thinking of a way to
incorporate it and we think every time i
say what the [ __ ] were they talking
about
we're gonna start bringing up a question
so that's pretty much gonna be the
reoccurring segment i think
but for now for now marty can you bring
up that [ __ ] question this is
from chris
on patreon we got chris on patreon here
k-r-i-s correct
yeah how has your experience selling
how is your experience selling weed
affected the way you run push trees do
you think
you learn skills that translate over and
help run a legal business or are they
completely different
150 percent we uh called our things
trees to tease that's that's what me
rose used to say
we should sell we but now we just sell
we uh shirts
so uh yes a hundred percent it's the
same [ __ ] thing
because when i'm like i got a pound if i
bust down to four qp's and i sell
and i got the [ __ ] pound for two
thousand dollars i gotta make five
hundred dollars a qp
to break even but if i sell them for 650
each i'm gonna make 150 on each and make
three three three three three that's
gonna be i mean 150
make 600 bucks on a pound if i get five
of those pounds and i sell them for the
same thing
i make three thousand dollars see how
that math is added up real quick
that's what i do about shirts like all
right if i get this run no no doesn't
matter how many shirts all right ready
go how much i spent all right we spent
thirty thousand dollars in these shirts
cool
how many shirts did i get all right
let's divide that bam what am i gonna
make per shirt
to make my money back say it's fifteen
dollars right cool so if i sell them for
30 bucks i make 15
right but after taxes after this okay
but i'm not making about
an eight bucks bob cool done maybe about
eight bucks sure after taxes
if i do this right so that's exactly how
i break it down how many
eights do i got to sell to make money
how many
shirts do i gotta sell eights are shirts
bongs are zips
all right make the same amount of money
off an eva dub an eighth
than you would off of a shirt make the
same amount of money off a bong
retail than i would off of selling a zip
to somebody
off the panel breakdown so it's direct
goddamn street science it's direct like
that's that's the only way in my brain
works like
all right what i gotta get what's the
what's the bottom line what do i have to
get all right cool cool now
these are all profit that's why i give a
lot of [ __ ] away because no i already
made my money i got it
i had to sell [ __ ] to 291 shirts to
make money off of that
design or [ __ ] like that that's how i do
i did it with wheat
alright cool if i sell all this i can
keep three
ounces that's what i used to do i said
cherry pick all the bomb ass nugs and
put them in these two
huge jars so if i got a pound i take a
qp out
and i only have to sell three qps to
make my profit back
do you see what i'm saying like if i
sell for 650 i got the pound for 200.
smoke for free basically
yeah so what's what's that uh ready
what's 650 for qp
and if i bought it for for 2000 bucks
ready
656.50 that's thirteen hundred dollars
what's another 650
listen we don't need to start loft in
math questions but 19 that's 1950 yeah
i'm 50 short of breaking even and i got
to smoke a qp
mm-hmm yeah it's a good deal oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah but ready if i broke it down
and i start busting down that qp
yeah what if i buzzed that on qp to zips
and i saw those zips for
200 a piece my qp went from 650 to 800.
now if i wanted to do that what happened
i made
what like two three hundred dollars more
so if i sold it all insists for 200 i'd
make 32 a pound i paid 200 i'd make 20.
risk goes up at the same time yeah and
your time
it's the time yeah so that's how it
works so that's what i do for clothes
like oh
we were 50 50 uh we're buying 50 shirts
when do i get a price breakdown like oh
when you do 200 and something something
shirts
okay how much less oh [ __ ] okay [ __ ]
all right i'm gonna make that much more
per shirt if i invest in myself more
and so it's a flip like it's just
flipping it's like oh i bought an eighth
how i started selling lead i bought a 10
sack and sold for 25 [ __ ] dollars
bought that 25 and i bought an eighth i
made more money and i doubled that and i
doubled that and i got a zip and then we
got a queue and then i got a pound
here we are so that's how it worked i
got a couple shirts and then i flipped
those and kept that and
flipped those the thing is with me i'm
really bad with money
so if i make a hundred thousand dollars
i spend a hundred thousand dollars back
in the business i don't ever pay myself
and i know i should
i always see it as i don't need anything
but my business needs to right i don't
yeah that's not exact advice i feel like
no that's that's how i do it
i'm saying i'm not good with it but now
that is good though but we have to pay
our
we have to pay ourselves legally down
legally we have to yeah
if you don't pay yourself as a business
owner you get fined 2
000 [ __ ] dollars yeah my my overall
point was
that's what you're supposed to be in
your 20s and your 30s and [ __ ] you
should be trying all day figure out how
you can flip up by the time you're 35
you're where you want to be
a hundred percent i i used to think
five years if this works in five years
like i never thought people were like oh
i'm trying to get rich today like
good luck if you get it good [ __ ] is it
quality is it lasting
will it transcend into other generations
of [ __ ]
and if it can then you win but if it
doesn't then you're just trying to get
rich quick
and what happens to one hit wonders
obscurity they're working at [ __ ]
walmart
which is not bad that's cool but if your
goal is to be a millionaire you can't
work at walmart unless you own that
[ __ ] which is sick in the franchise
oh hey you got some money if you all you
trap kids out there here's some advice
you got a [ __ ] hundred thousand
dollars in trap money
make that [ __ ] legal somehow find a way
to make that legal start [ __ ]
put it into a business that you can do
with low maintenance that way you can
start
building up legal money and then go buy
a little caesars
go franchise a little caesars or a
dominoes in your town because
what doesn't go out of [ __ ] business
fast food
gyms little caesars
five dollar pizza it's a never ghetto in
the [ __ ] america yeah that's true
they never go away
they're never gonna go away every high
school kid of the planet has five
dollars to split with their homies and
they all get one pizza
that's why i say everything like don't
know don't make a [ __ ] fancy italian
restaurant in a poor town
you know we're not gonna change the
society of your town
if it's too expensive why the [ __ ] are
you doing it don't do a steakhouse in
merced
they're sizzler yeah you see a lot of
people buying into franchises like that
buy into a franchise man buy into a
mcdonald's
system yeah it's kind of like buying a
property like i wanna i wanna
build a [ __ ] neighborhood that's why
i have a homie dude i told you that my
homie's building a neighborhood right
now it's [ __ ] awesome
so yes chris from patreon your question
directly everything like we said the
other day i was trying to do math i go i
don't know
and i went wait that's like 48 pounds
i remember that i broke it down in my
head and went damn dude i only get it if
you're talking about
bad breeds and [ __ ] yeah which i might
add but if we do this
this this that's one pound oh man my
brain sucks
and um there we are thank you chris from
patreon yes
your question 100 it goes directly into
it that's how i think about everything
try to flip things make more here flip
that
but the only reason why is like all my
money goes back into businesses and
we're starting
i'm starting another business with my
homie this month and another another
business my other friend comes out next
month
or it's it's never ending but it's gonna
be like
you have eight giant companies in ten
years
yeah i know i was broke for 20 years
doing
it but it's worth it because i just want
to be
old and raise dogs when i'm like old ass
man
and drink welch's grape juice
the point is to comfortably do what you
want yeah i'm just trying to get there
we're trying to get there so uh
watch these [ __ ] ads thanks
guys
thank you thanks uh manscape to
appreciate it
i was about to pull it up thanks
manscaped but no for real um the way i
think about it guys is uh
late night tv jimmy kimmel all that
stuff he doesn't do ad reads
why because there's [ __ ] commercials
he doesn't have to do the ad read there
are no commercials on this network
because they're not a network
so that's our commercial see what i'm
saying and we put out so much [ __ ] for
free we do so much that
these ad reads are allowing us to do
more we're trying to hire more people so
we can go to two episodes a week
i think two episodes a week is the goal
i would [ __ ] love it it makes me have
more to do it's like
i feel like after day three i'm like all
right ready for another you ready for
another one that's how i always feel
like when
when's the next monday [ __ ] and i know
all you guys agree because i get all the
comments so
guys um that was the most precise i
think
solo episode i've done i try to keep it
and not rant
city everything and oh guys we're making
merch and rant city is coming soon all
right
we got some merch coming it's [ __ ]
baller but we want to introduce rant
city a little more
we're going to come out with a little
segment it's going to be pretty cool
and uh yeah uh marty what else you got
to say man
we kind of teased the idea of a live
stream podcast on instagram at least i
did yeah yeah yeah yeah
gonna be in hawaii apparently oh that's
real
problem but the fans like the idea
for your anniversary yeah go in the
other room go on zoom for four hours
and chill with us
i'm kidding i'm kidding wait who would
man the camera
we can't do it without you anyway unless
nick's like
no oh i got it yeah well i mean nick is
a [ __ ]
that's true that's true it's just me and
nick facetime and marty in hawaii
it looks nice there marty april in the
back spits
your ass yeah we got to get april to
[ __ ]
defend herself yeah yeah
you know what another thing dude we have
to play basketball
because you're a [ __ ] college you
want to you that's what you do play
basketball
i want to see that's what i used to do
though i know but you it never goes away
even though you're not as good you still
know how to do [ __ ] yeah
i mean well you know how this this post
up hat i will never totally
did i ever tell you real quick before i
leave did ever tell you what happened
when i tried to proper basketball
every time i'm good at basketball party
listen i've edited a [ __ ] video you
on five thousand milligrams
you're right and you referenced hot
sauce man and that's what i
reference listen leave in the comments i
appreciate
yo hot sauce was my favorite one bro he
was my that
that was it yeah he started doing the
shirt [ __ ] and the twister was hot sauce
same yeah all i did was practice i had
the long hair and my [ __ ]
air american eagle shirts selling sacks
of the gangsters and shaking the
how many times i got in fights almost
because i would shake the [ __ ] out of
these hood ass dudes
they're all in tim's and [ __ ] no like
their baby basketball i used to live in
the uh at the grove and there's a get a
house apartment
and there was like these hood ass dudes
that always play basketball and there's
a little fat me with long hair
looking like rosie o'donnell and [ __ ]
and i'm over here smoking joints and
blunts with my homies and then just
oh let me play i shook a fool to his
[ __ ] ass once and got him a swamp
he got up and swallowed me and his
homies held him back and i was like yo
what the [ __ ] you want to do man go go
less hard it's just i was a fat little
mexican kid and all these tall black
dudes are like
you ain't [ __ ] i'm like no i'll probably
miss
but i'm gonna shake the [ __ ] out of you
first now it's more like
i'm gonna give up bro i'm not good
anymore i'm not good anymore i can't i
can't shake nobody no more but i used to
be
shockingly good and my homie joe joe
from all story times he was a bomb ass
basketball player
and he always shook the [ __ ] out of me
and it pissed me off he's good as [ __ ]
at basketball
anyway i brought that up i went to i did
all that [ __ ] right and one [ __ ] i was
juking the
[ __ ] out of andre guzman [ __ ] elbowed
me in the mouth one time one on one
because i shook him so
[ __ ] hard and he pulled the [ __ ]
and then scored and goes i won
all right [ __ ] you i'm scushion and i
was like it's cause i shook you huh
i remember that i was like it's because
i shook you up see people thought i was
cute because i was a [ __ ] white boy
doing this [ __ ] they got violent with
you
i wasn't the [ __ ] ghetto man still i
mean the thing is when people get real
embarrassed like when people get mad
embarrassed
they want to fight always oh every time
i was like
chilling with like the super hood
mexican fools everyone's trying
someone's trying to
try to fight you i've been so almost
nobody wants to get shaken shaken by the
fat kid and when everybody goes
and then it's real badly i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry
but yeah dude not anymore but um
i went to basketball tryouts and my
thing in my head was like don't be a
ball hog
do not be a ball i try for seventh grade
basketball tonight don't be a ball hug
don't [ __ ] show off that's all i keep
saying don't show off don't try to juke
[ __ ]
and pass the ball stop being a ball hog
i didn't make the team
next morning talk to the coach goes you
just don't take the
initiative with the ball enough i need a
leader he's what he said for your
position
you don't take shots you almost you took
one shot yesterday he's like i need
someone that's more active
in the offense and i went no no
way did you tell me i remember he told
me that i was just like
my homie anthony avla made it he's just
fat like me and i was just like
i was so i was like i would have threw
it off the backboard and [ __ ] myself
[ __ ]
i would have done everything you know if
she escalade that's me
that's me i swear dude i would have
never thought an escalated gun in my
life
this glaze was so hard big [ __ ]
just
wow that's hilarious oh
i feel i feel like our demo might not
know what the [ __ ] we're talking about
i don't know go look up and one mix
tapes all right items one through four
oh i had them on dvd the red one
because they used to drop with the
shorts and sneakers i never got any of
those powers [ __ ] i just got the dvds
the the burn copies
they got all the burnt copies i got one
though that was in the real because the
real dvd case though it was the red one
yeah was it black that [ __ ] is legendary
either way [ __ ] man uh
yo professor shout out to professor that
[ __ ] is on youtube yeah
he's on instagram do you see him go to
the prison and shake the [ __ ] out of
everybody
yo go on man go to venice beach you
suppose got it hard enough you know
we're shaking the [ __ ] out of him come
on
dude but yeah professor man i loved all
that [ __ ] uh
anyway that's my story i did not make
the basketball team because
i did the opposite of what i usually do
and hogged the ball and
it was great i'm so happy i didn't make
it i'm i'm lying
i was pissed all right i was [ __ ]
heated i was so mad
um i think that's it oh yeah i brought
it up because we gotta play basketball
because i've never
you i know you know how to play
basketball i have one other friend a
shout out to [ __ ] ace remember when
he came to play basketball with me
i didn't know my friend he was he was a
college basketball player i didn't know
people were that good in person
like now that i see that go oh nba
players are magnificent then
because you haven't played in five years
and this is what you're doing you hit
like 35 threes in a row yeah no i'm not
like that
you're just hitting with the wrist shot
over and [ __ ] over dude
nah i'm good bro i'm good i'm fat now
this is some [ __ ] um yeah so i think
that's everything to add man i think
we're sick
we got the 360 cam now so we could fly
yes we have 360 cam so you can be like
[ __ ] hanging out like 70 show with us
soon
shout out to matt alonso for showing us
that [ __ ] that's when he that's when we
found out about it
um guys yeah i think that's it man this
is the most precise
uh and honestly i'm gonna say it
i feel like i need i feel unenergetic
today
i don't know my bad if if it didn't feel
like i feel like it was off today
i'm sorry but i just wanted to say that
in case somebody was out there like
don't worry it never happened again all
right
i feel like i don't know i don't feel
like you're off i feel like you're going
on three hours of sleep
maybe that's what it is and i keep
thinking about total recall
and the [ __ ] the baby in his stomach
sharon stone you [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm a sports [ __ ]
come on the podcast man i'm just gonna
sit there guys i love you
i don't think there's going to be
anything beyond me just telling them how
much i love them like
like arnold put your arm out and i'm
going to hang on it i can't do pull ups
but let me hang on it
let me hang on your episode 100 yeah
like yo
and uh yeah i know kindergarten yeah i
know by a hundred i'm doing pool
off arnold's arm that's the new goal i
want him to hold me like he
uh by the back of my overalls like he
does that kid in kindergarten cops boys
yes but remember when he picks up the
fat kid whose lunches are these
and he's holding them up and he spits it
out
i [ __ ] love arnold schwarzenegger and
we're gonna end on that note arnold if
you're out there
i know you have kids hey arnold's kids i
will get you
high for the rest of your life just
bring your [ __ ] dad on my show
and then i'm going to go who is your
daddy and what does he do
i'm going to run up the [ __ ] building
it's a ferret oh bro everything i'm
saying now is just total recall on
kindergarten cop i'm out of here
i can't say nothing about commando this
is my my weak arm
god i love arnold schwarzenegger so
[ __ ] much i have a statue you in my
house
that's a toy but statue all right guys
i'm sorry for everyone driving i'm over
here ranting and [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] high
i'm going on mid hours of sleep so let's
get this done marty anything else you
want to add
thank you guys we're feeling great we're
about to take this [ __ ] to the next
level and it just feels amazing that
we're up and running and
everybody's enjoying themselves level up
oh my god that sounded like a real hello
oh wow i'm gonna start doing
more of this video game voiceovers or
some [ __ ]
you're dead yep i'm gonna start doing
that gta
um i know everybody i'll say one more
thing i'm such a random [ __ ]
what was it think it's called apex or
legends or
whatever game has the guy road hog in it
there's a game and he's like a dwarf or
an elf but his name is roadhog
i think it's the game called legends
yeah char
put like video game legends roadhog
overwatch sorry overwatch that's what it
is this guy named roadhog
um if you want to check it out on
youtube there's a thing it's called he
said my name it's my little brother
he has a youtube channel and uh this guy
i got i was hooking up with weed and
[ __ ] he knows
um he knows the dudes that do
optimus prime at universal all right
so i had them say my little brother's
name and like bring him out in front of
the crowd when they're doing their whole
speech
and he's like only one person could save
the planet with me he's all
rocco and he calls him out and i filmed
the whole thing
and my little brother posted it on
youtube and he got monetized off it he
got so many views
wow my little brother got like a 20
check the other day all right he's all
hyped
and um it's on youtube still and it's
it's [ __ ] awesome
anyway the guy came out the guy that
does the voice does the voice for this
roadhog
and the second he talked to go how many
balls do you smoke a day
this i swear here which does he look
like seth rogen and [ __ ]
four-year-old virgin to quote it again
oh they're just like i smoked weed
that's how he looked i'm like
you know what you look you look like you
smell like bowls you know what i mean
like he looks like the bottom of your
thumb
has hell of black ash on it and uh yeah
he's that guy so forever
all you video game fans out there
roadhog's cool all right
and i'm gonna leave it on that random
ass
[ __ ] topic why did i bring it up no
i did oh video game voiceovers
i'm out of here man this is terrible i
keep talking um
all right let's do another ad read let's
do another ad right after we're done
with this podcast thank you guys so much
for watching
uh we gotta start doing them before
you're right i'm [ __ ] high uh
thank you guys so much for watching this
is episode 15 correct
i believe so um that sounds about right
yeah
episode 15 guys exactly three months
today thank you so much
[ __ ] appreciate you guys um yeah i
think that's it
this has been the dope as usual podcast
once again we're here to talk about life
problems drugs accomplishments
and everything in between and today was
a lot of everything in between
thank you guys for hanging out we
appreciate it have a dope ass day
yo that weed i should have bought a lot
more of it it was
[ __ ] fire
i hate that bob parker
i'm just thinking about happy gilmore
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh no now you've had enough
[ __ ]
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
you